kids
dead
half were killed this is senator
murphy's full address
mr president
they're 14 kids
dead
in an elementary school in texas right
now
what are we doing
what are we doing
just days after a shooter walked into a
grocery store
to gun down
african-american patrons we have another
sandy hook on our hands
what are we doing
there been more mass shootings than days
in the year
our kids are living in fear
every single time they set foot in the
classroom because they think they're
going to be next
what are we doing
why do you spend all this time running
for the united states senate
why do you go through all the hassle
of getting this job
of putting yourself in a position of
authority
if your answer
is that as this slaughter increases as
our kids run for their lives we do
nothing
what are we doing
why are you here
if not
to solve
a problem as existential as this
this isn't inevitable
these kids weren't unlucky
this only happens in this country
and nowhere else
nowhere else do little kids go to school
thinking that they might be shot that
day
nowhere else do parents have to talk to
their kids as i have had to do about why
they got locked into a bathroom and told
to be quiet for five minutes just in
case a bad man entered that building
nowhere else does that happen except
here in the united states of america and
it is a choice
it is our choice
to let it continue
what
are we doing
in sandy hook elementary school after
those kids came back
into those classrooms
they had to adopt a practice
in which there would be a safe word that
the kids would say
if they started to get thoughts in their
brain about what they saw that day
if they started to get nightmares during
the day
reliving stepping over their classmates
bodies as they tried to flee
the school in one classroom that word
was monkey
and over and over and over through the
day kids would stand up and yell monkey
and a teacher or a paraprofessional
would have to go over to that kid
take them out of the classroom talk to
them about what they had seen
work them through their issues
sandy hook will never ever be the same
this community in texas will never ever
be the same why
why are we here
if not to try to make sure that fewer
schools and fewer communities go
through what sandy hook has gone through
what yuvaldi is going through our heart
is breaking for these families
every ounce of love and thoughts and
prayers we can send
we are sending
but i'm here on this floor
to beg
to literally get down on my hands and
knees and beg my colleagues
find a path forward here
work with us
to find a way
to pass laws that make this less likely
i understand my republican colleagues
will not agree to everything that i may
support but there is a common
denominator that we can find
there is a place where we can achieve
agreement
that
may not
guarantee
that america never ever again sees a
mass shooting
that may not overnight cut in half the
number of murders that happen in america
it will not solve
the problem of american
violence by itself
but by doing something
we at least
stop sending this quiet message of
endorsement
to these killers whose brains are
breaking who see the highest levels of
government doing nothing
shooting
after shooting
what are we doing
why are we here
what are we doing
senator chris murphy
what are we doing huh
let me show you what
let me just show you what we're doing
and why nothing is being done
there it is
senator romney
accepted 13.6 million in donations from
the nra
senator burr 6.9 million in donations
from the nra roy blunt 4.5 million
and donations from the end all right
senator tom tell us 4.4 million senator
cory garda three-point nominee marco
rubio 3.3 senator joni erst 3.1 tom
cotton
2 million holy
1.4 1.4
miss mcconnell 1.3
and [ __ ] crews 176.
yeah
sad isn't it
sandy hook all over again
all over again
and nothing will be done
only in this country
that
that congressman was running
you know in scotland they had a
a shooting and i think they banned
guns or whatever and
they all stopped same with australia
just here
why because the republican politicians
don't give a [ __ ]
about you
or your children
they don't care
they've proven it time and time again
governor abbott
signed
laws bills
or whatever you want to call it
that made texas
a second amendment sanctuary state
and he was so proud about it look what i
did
yeah
yeah abbott look what you did
this is on you
[Music]
this is on you ted cruz
as you sit idly by and do nothing and
then stand there and say look nothing's
gonna
nothing's gonna work if we do this it's
been proven [ __ ]
teddy raphael
you're so full of [ __ ]
and that same ted cruz and greg abbott
are
doing an and right
nra event this weekend in austin texas
or houston or something like that
yep
on the weekend
following
this massacre
do you know these kids i hate this i
hate to be
you know
dark here but it's true these kids were
shot up so badly that they couldn't even
identify them
couldn't even identify them that's how
badly they were shot up
and yet nothing
is being done
nothing
i'm so [ __ ] sick of it
how many more kids have to die
huh ted
how many more mitch
marco
abbott
bobert
green
gates how many more
how many more
bozo bird is busy posting with her guns
posting pictures with the guns
hi mark p shorty one
hey mark hurley
somebody yes it is one ker
thank you one
more bad news
rest in peace ray leota
great actor and a great man i i was
executive producer of the stephanie
miller show and i booked ray as a guest
and he couldn't have been a nicer more
humble guy
died at the
young age of 67.
awful
uh hello giraud
hello
ramone
joni heisenberg the shooner the shooter
didn't act alone he was enabled and
empowered by every lawmaker who blocks
common sense gun control
facebook people join this broadcast you
can support my page by sending stars a
digital gif that helps me earn money
for us richie is here wayne berkey
that's how you could donate wayne
carly and martin from iowa
joni heisenberg greg abbott attended a
fundraiser after the
u of eight school shooting
john deaf
tammy pearson from facebook linda mcewan
johnny wright
[Applause]
to squeegee why don't politicians get
whacked
well they do if
you heard of lincoln and jonathan
kennedy jr
i mean john yeah jfk amen
kenny gill from melbourne australia
carlene martin uh roberta knight nancy
cox michelle johnson-warnist
anita blake i'm stevenson from south
carolina
lolina diana olson captain terp martha
salinas
uh
jackie hobson andrea brauer
oh i forgot i got to give you the wrench
sorry andrea leslie ramsden
um
joy hein bicycle bike 42
uh uh and uh
even on a day like this the uh
the trolls can't stop but
continue their poor [ __ ] stage dog is
here
yeah joni i know a lot of people are
telling me that i saw your interview
with monique i don't think she's coming
from a good place a lot of people saying
that i know
you're not the first person to say that
i i you know i love monique but i you
know i get i get why you would say that
just by judging by some of her
questioning
but let's bring in
the
uh
uh the resident genius and let me just
say i'm
this is going to be i'm going to be
leaving around 4 20 today
which is uh
120 i got to go to west palm to do a uh
the mscs podcast so this will be a
shortened show so who better to have on
at this time than our genius our friend
our pal
house sparks ladies and gentlemen hiya
how are you doing bro i'm good how are
you uh you are you're in west palm right
now i'm in miami beach but i'm all right
palm yeah gotcha the the the miami i
have the key
to uh uh miami beach island which is a
specific i was given the key to the city
by the mayor there so if you if you get
locked out i can i can fly in and help
you out um how do you have the key
what do you mean how do i not have the
key to every city
the good i do are you kidding me
i should have a janitor's ring of like
city keys that i just walk around with
in case some on one of those pull cords
so i can
open any city no i'm just scruffy and
you can yeah
uh just it looks like you have a little
mustache growing i do have a little bit
of one i'm just this is how long it
takes
so how this is a really horrible i do
want to give kudos to jimmy kimmel who
did an awesome job in his opening
uh uh last night about the shooting when
i and i've had my problems with jimmy
kimmel ever since he
sabotaged you know my boss jay leno for
no reason but he really did a good job
and i asked you how
just like i played you know you know
that congressman or senator chris murphy
i don't know if you saw his speech you
know what are we doing
right what are we doing huh what's going
on
um
uh
next to nothing um i mean ultimately
um we have a
um
a situation where
democratic voters specifically hyper
left-leaning democratic voters have been
operating with this feat to the fire
uh attitude towards democrats for so
long that every step forward we get
where we're we get close to having a
legit control where we can actually
implement some of these changes we
always get kicked back
in you know in the midterms like because
there's this
window of like do everything now or
nothing counts and and the reality is is
that
that has a direct impact on our ability
to legislate on something as big as gun
control
because you're never going to get it
unless you have 60 or more
period end of story that's what we're
doing i don't want to get i don't want
to hear any [ __ ] about what democrats
aren't doing what biden administration's
not doing i don't even want to hear
about what republican interference is
running until we have 60 senators
it's a [ __ ] conversation
because all it takes is one and rand
paul's enough
and and none of this stuff moves forward
now that said one of the other uh things
that we have against it is when the when
the bills to deal with gun control which
is written into the constitution a well
regulated militia every aspect of it we
need to know where every gun is in the
country
at all times because if we need to call
up a militia but because we're because
we're being attacked by a foreign force
we need to know who to call so all guns
need to be registered and and how much
ammo you have uh per household that's
part of a well-regulated militia i don't
hear any of this [ __ ] about 2a
purists who are like wait you know no
violation of the freedom to have guns is
sacrosanct about it no it is within the
regard of having a well-regulated
militia so all background checks are on
the table universal background checks
are on the table to make sure you're on
the team because you can't well regulate
a militia if if the person that's buying
a gun is a member of a terrorist force
or has been emailing al qaeda and isis
regularly so i don't hear any [ __ ] from
republicans about any any gun controls a
slippery slope to the elimination of all
guns that's not the case we elected the
democrat that said buy a shotgun so piss
off with that nonsense but i but the
biggest problem i i have
is that
we are
not
voting
as democrats with enough consistency and
regularity to [ __ ] at anyone else
about gun control not getting passed oh
hell that's what uh someone in the chat
uh robin brazil says oh my god you're
blaming the democrats for this i i don't
think that's what you're doing no i'm
i'm blaming democratic voters
i'm voting the half-assed
to two legs in the same pair of pants
there's no difference between the bodies
i don't know maybe i'll take a chance on
donald trump because i've been told
hillary clinton who helped get s-chip
started is a warm mom mongering baby
eater [ __ ] that we have a responsibility
this is a democracy and we live in a
democracy and if you and and who i'm
blaming is the people who show up half
the time or [ __ ] about who they can get
and always keep us without grasping
outside of grasping distance of a 60
vote majority in the senate and an
enough of a majority in the house and
even in red states where you're like
well what's the difference my vote's not
going to count it's going to go to a
republican if you can eat into their
mandate by showing them that not all of
their constituencies agree with this
[ __ ] that the democrat got way more
votes than they should have that will
force them
to to factor that into their thinking
and until everybody
and until everybody [ __ ] shows up
and like i said we have 48 democrats in
the senate 48 no and i don't mean cousin
mansion and cinema including them we
have 48 we have two independents who are
too chicken [ __ ] to call themselves
democrats
because
yeah yeah santas and king
sanders and king and they
have to pretend to be independents in
their state just to get [ __ ] elected
we have a branding issue and we have a
responsibility issue in democratic
voters and i'm up to [ __ ] here with
people like tyt bitching about this when
when anna kasparian is doing this whole
rant i'm not voting for any democrats
anymore because
three donald trump supreme court
justices handed the roe v wade to the
right-wing religious side of the court
that's not democrats fault if it's
anything it's democratic voters fault
for not showing up and you're damned
straight that's where i'm gonna throw
the responsibility because that's where
i am i'm taking that responsibility i
vote every [ __ ] time and i don't and
and there are more of us technically
than there are of them yep and and if we
don't have 60 senators
and at least a
50 to 70 vote margin in the house
we're not done working
yep period and and honest to god as long
as there is a uh you know we don't have
a filibuster breaking majority
elected i don't even know why people
think we have the right to claim
control and superiority when we have 48
elected
we used to have 60 we don't anymore and
it wasn't because we the the nation got
more conservative because it [ __ ]
well didn't no
so like
that it's up to us that's all and get
mentioned out won't do [ __ ] the squeegee
i just saw that and think no keep
manchin in there and make him irrelevant
by getting eight to ten more senators
elected
yup because if you get rid of him you
give control just getting rid of mansion
alone gives control of the senate to the
republicans then you want to talk about
what gets done on on gun control now
that's the other aspect
all or nothing bills aren't going to
pass the senate until that happens if we
put together a whole package
comprehensive gun control and we put it
there it's always going to sink
but
there are elements of the oh an angel
just got their wings
[Laughter]
every
every
uh there are elements of gun control
that in the in light of these kind of
circumstances most republicans are on
board with and you could get through a
single note
wins and then eventually you're playing
a symphony one note at a time and for
the example in this one so the the
shooter in texas this one
if you watch the ted cruz clip he
rattles off
like
you don't know how to turn your
notifications off you don't know how to
put it on
privacy i was waiting for you to scold
me on this all right so uh i'm fine but
um this is this is important um
the the shooter in texas
was not involuntarily committed when he
went to a temporary cycle
and because he was not involuntarily
committed it did not affect his ability
to buy a gun because it was a temporary
cycle then he went willingly
it doesn't affect your ability to get do
that now i believe i think it should
work out that if you are on a if you are
a cycle for any reason especially if
it's about harming yourself or others
that has to
put you on they have to like red flag
that that says you can't buy a gun for
five years
yeah period end of story for five years
now if you think it's unnecessary and
your parents are religious nuts and they
put you in because you're transgender
and they think you're insane and they're
trying to mess with you you could go
before a judge and go your honor my
parents are crazy i am now 18 years old
and i would like to be able to purchase
a gun because i live out in the middle
of nowhere and it's for self-defense and
yada yada and i can prove that i am
saying it's just my parents overreacted
in this situation you can have a hearing
to return your your rights to purchase a
gun
to you so you can't just and you know
everybody can't just involuntarily uh
you know or just have a cycle on their
kid just to guarantee that their kid
isn't a school shooter like that kind of
stuff
that that's that's doable that's a
single note law you could pass
um uh based on well-regulated militia
and standard gun regulations about who
can have and can't have a gun um it
would just tighten up a loophole
essentially that there's a difference
between uh you know going in on a cycle
versus being involuntarily committed
there's there is no major distinction if
you need to go to a mental hospital and
especially as a teenage boy
for a couple of days
and it ain't rehab most of the time it's
self-harm or harming others and in those
cases you you need to be the the idea
that you could he bought this gun on his
18th birthday or a day after
the idea that you could just do that as
soon as you're legal without having some
time pass for you to be evaluated again
is insane because if he's if that that
happened when he was 17
years and
360 days old
five days later he can go buy a gun what
are you talking about so that that i
think is a loophole you could tighten
um that would get rid of that aspect of
it this would not affect their their
open carry their you know uh permit less
uh this concealed carry wouldn't affect
any of that stuff
um so
republicans could be you know
persuaded
by their own voters to pass something
like that it's a it's a tiny little
thing so they can say they did something
i don't care if they're going to pat
themselves in the back they do it with
infrastructure anyways and they voted
against the damn thing it's not the
point it's about saving it's about
saving lives and i can sacrifice ego to
some of these idiots with an idea that
democrats came up with um you know any
time if it will mean it does something
to move that ball down the field now
again
whether that that's a that's still a
long shot with the republicans being the
way they are but it is something you
could get past i mean even in abbott
state
there was a there was a kid walking
towards school a school
yesterday this morning
that was arrested at school he had an
ar-15 and an ak-47
uh uh style pistol like it was like a
pistol designed to look like an ak-47
and he was seen walking towards the
school
with this stuff on the police were
called they showed up he was in the
school already he did he didn't have the
guns on him he had put him in his car so
basically he'd walk he left the house in
his car walked home got his guns went
back put him in the car for whatever
whenever school let out or whatever he
was planning and they arrested him for
and here it is
having guns in a gun free zone
the only thing that [ __ ] stopped this
shooting in texas was that texas schools
in this particular area are gun-free
[ __ ] zones it's the only thing they
were able to hold them on and the
problem with a lot of these open carry
free carry walk around it doesn't matter
if i want to
carry one in a in a starbucks i have the
right to do the difference between right
and responsibility and most people you
know especially when it comes to guns
most responsible gun owners would never
act like this so anybody who's walking
around with an ar-15 and going into
starbucks going i'm showing off my
freedom is not a responsible actor and
secondly all that does is a
and and these guys always if a cop comes
up and goes hey buddy where you headed
with that [ __ ] thing
all their response is don't you
violating my rights you don't even have
the right to ask me and all that does is
create a a culture a situation where
somebody can pick a target
and nobody can bother them until they're
in shooting distance and that is mad
that's ridiculous
what do you think about joni heisman
said uh she says abbott allowed texans
to carry handguns without a license or
training
the blood is on his hands i i think a
lot of the blood is on his ends of
course well i mean i i think the the
ammo sexual gun culture um has a lot of
culpability in this you know that they
they deify
having guns
um
so of course they're they're part of
this that said
this wasn't part of that the concealed
carry aspect of it none of that was an
aspect of this what the aspect of this
was that loophole i just talked to you
about
because
because he should have been disqualified
from
buying a gun based on his psych eval but
he wasn't because he went willingly
because his parents said we're going to
take away your xbox if you don't go that
kind of [ __ ] and and and his grandmother
did um now he killed his grandmother and
i think his mom i like his mother was a
drug addict and his grandmother had
removed him from his mom's care
and she and his mother lived in his one
of his grandmother's other houses and
the tweets he sent out i'm gonna kill my
mother or i'm gonna kill my grandmother
and then 15 minutes before i'm gonna you
know i'm gonna
do a mastering right or something like
that yeah yeah and so um a lot of this
has to do i mean there's a
you know
there's a lot in this
that
but you know he was taught he tortured a
cat like there's that story where he
texted his friend about him beheading a
cat and keeping the head under his bed
and uh
old school i mean this is old school
serial killer [ __ ] this is like
no totally or bundy or dahmer any of
these guys like that's what they do
yeah that's what they do and so when you
have when you have somebody who
and i think the psyche valve thing had
to do with them finding the head of the
cat under his bed and him saying he
didn't feel anything when he did it
and there's some other stuff about it
but again
if that's not a red hell what the
exactly exactly but here's the thing it
is a red flag for kids doing themselves
in it's a red flag for self-harm but
it's not it doesn't chart in texas to a
level where you'll remove the ability
for somebody to buy a gun you know 15
days after that happens
as long as he turns 18 it's stupid right
yeah question now
i'm sorry for interrupting but
because i think i heard or i read that
in scotland they had a shooting and they
banned the gun and it stopped australia
stopped yeah that was actually two
countries that i heard so right so what
the
how were they able to do it when not
what the [ __ ] because they don't have a
constitutional guarantee for the right
to bear arms in their in their
constitution at all that doesn't exist
and and uh
that i mean that is the primary aspect
of it now australia doesn't have it
because england was too far away and
once they got their independence it was
large they got their independence
largely because they weren't worth the
trip
uh scotland never had its independence
but modernization in the and the joining
of scotland ireland and england in terms
of world war one and world war ii
steady this idea that they were going to
have some sort of tyrannical uprising
against the crown at some point that the
you know that the united kingdom was
recognized as in
um often you know we're the united
states of america we are in one
federalist system
the
the uk and the european union are not
they are you know it's a union of
countries with with levels of
sovereignty and they you know they agree
to
you know work on certain issues together
that's not how the united states works
and so the languaging is very different
so england's rules about guns don't
affect scotland's rules they can make up
their own rules about it and a lot of it
has to do with the fact that england was
constantly invading
scotland and scotland was always trying
to fight back for their freedom if you
are braveheart fan and so there was
never a point where they were gonna you
know
where like the idea that they would have
to write something in of course you're
gonna be armed of course you're gonna
have a shotgun in the house or a rifle
or whatever is available they just have
limits on weapons of war in the in the
household
because they didn't want any english
sympathizers in scotland to start
stockpiling you know putting a cannon in
their backyard
so there you know there are rules about
that we have very distinct we have a
constitutional
um hurdle to clear about these things
now i think the one thing that hasn't
been
um
you know
been hammered enough is the
well-regulated militia part
that's the issue
that you know they don't i don't know
why democrats need to bring this up
a well-regulated militia being necessary
to uh you know to a free people or
whatever uh you know the right to to
bear arms will not be infringed right
that's the uh okay
your your right to bear arms isn't
infringed but we can sure as [ __ ] know
that you have them where they are how
many you have what kind of ammo you have
where you're keeping it we can put
limitations on what can be used inside
and outside the country because we have
limitations about like military the
military policing citizens
we have a difference between the uh fbi
and the cia like we make all these
distinctions the same thing is is a
distinction for citizens because the
problem that i have with the tyrannical
argument that these [ __ ] always
bring up is that most of the time these
the people who are screaming about
tyranny and the tyrannical government's
going to come and take your stuff
first of all you have legal protections
that are greater than the second
amendment protecting you from the
seizure of your property without due
course or proof that you're committing
some sort of a crime you have a
protection against unreasonable search
and seizure you don't have the military
operating on u.s territory towards
citizenry it's a you have you are
guaranteed the right to representation
in court all these things that that
supersede you needing to
have a standoff at your [ __ ] house
okay you have all these other things you
are not an island you're not talking
about somebody who's living like peter
thiel on a [ __ ] oil rig so all that
argument is [ __ ] but the
well-regulated militia part
and the limitation of what you can have
on your homestead without special
permission
a lot of times if you're a collector or
you're you know you
you for free speech reasons you're a
armor for movies and television and you
have you know dumbed down versions of
these weapons or whatever that like
there are all kinds of exceptions that
can be made but in general you have to
tell everybody like hey guys i need a 50
cal machine gun why well because um i
have a hog problem and there's they
breed like rats and they come over the
hill and they ate my kid and i that's
the only thing i could do and i'm nine
miles away from you know nine hours away
from any police officers of note so i
need a 50 cal like that kind of
silliness and everybody goes you're a
dip [ __ ] put up a fence and um you know
dick williams here the only way to get a
bad guy with a gun is a good guy with a
gun there was a [ __ ] armed guard
there
right and
and he shot the arm guard what the [ __ ]
are you talking about baby well here's
here's here if you believe that is true
one of the ways you stop the bad guys
with guns is limit how many shots people
that are not authorized to be someplace
by our tax dollars and our agreement um
the limit the number of shots they're
able to fire before they're out so that
those good guys with a gun have a better
chance at
protecting other people secondarily good
guy with a gun if you can't hit what
you're shooting at when somebody walks
into a bar and starts flailing around
and all you do is over the bar start
emptying clips into the crowd you're as
much a bad guy as they are crossfire
makes you a bad guy secondarily you want
a well-regulated militia you want the
cops to be aware that you have a gun of
note and if you're on scene you're
you're the good guy so they don't show
up and because you won but you're still
holding your gun they don't roll up and
go drop it you're like but i bang you
know because 19 shots were fired off in
30 seconds someplace also
uh good guys with guns all good guys
with guns if you're a good guy with a
gun you should be completely for smart
guns guns that only fire with uh with
your fingerprint or or or some sort of
sensor on your watch that allow them to
be fired because nobody can take your
gun away and use it to be a bad guy so
that isn't enough
so yeah well like yeah like i mean they
were trying to sell them years ago and
in new jersey there was a shop and they
got sued and by the nra everybody the
nra is always trying to stop smart guns
because if you if smart guns start
making and by the way they're going to i
got news for you where where the future
moves forward eventually
guns without some sort of lock on them
in public are going to be illegal you
can brandish them all the [ __ ] you want
but we need to know who's shooting and
why and if you have a good reason you're
not in trouble you're self-defense
that's fine right because i have a
friend who says
you know he's trying to like
you know he's you know he's making a
reference to a chris rock bit saying
what we should do is charge a hell of a
lot for the bullets right let's go after
the bullets
is
it sounds crazy but is it
yeah no i mean uh bullets uh it you
watch the freak out when bullets get
expensive
um you know whenever the the the issue
that
that comes up with that is
you're talking about private companies
having the ability to sell it they can
set whatever price they want you could
tax the bullets you could put a tax on
on bullets to make them you know for
civilian use almost impossible unless
you could buy them at like like if
you're at a range you can buy bullets at
a uh you know at a lower rate so if you
want to go to a shooting range and just
spend a lot of ammo that's fine if you
wanna you know
if you buy ammo from a registered dealer
for example um they would have you know
some sort of marker aspect on them that
you're responsible for like having a
little thing that stamps the shell
that says it was bought at this store at
this date that kind of stuff all of
those things would help immensely and it
would also
make the the sales people
a little more nervous and on the ball
about who the hell they are giving this
[ __ ] to yeah so if they don't care
there's box after box after box i don't
care i'm not even gonna look because i
know it's gonna be horrible you know
some dudes walking in bitching about his
wife and freaking out about alimony and
yadda yadda and he's buying you know uh
hollow points and you're like all right
you know you know some shit's about to
go down but these guys just like i don't
care i don't care it's not like it's
coming back here
who cares right that you put you've got
to put
the people along the chain of guns and
ammo need to have some skin in the game
benny loco thanks for the five bucks i
want to play i don't know if you saw
this although i'm sure you have because
because you like me you are
news junkie but right but i will uh
i mean
i think this was kind of cool maybe it's
political theater but i thought it was
kind of cool
this is what i was queuing up uh hold on
did you see this how
which one the
um
this is better o'rourke yes [ __ ] at
greg abbott's [ __ ]
yes
check it out
newscast with the exchange between
governor abbott and former congressman
beta o'rourke but the conversation is
happening across the u.s last night
former spurs player and murdered
the sale unrepentant he tells our team
that he's or any current laws would have
flagged the shooter since he did not
have a criminal history
there are instances not many of them but
there are instances where someone that
doesn't have a criminal history that
doesn't have a history of mental illness
nonetheless [ __ ] ton of them horrific
and unspeakable crime and you obviously
you can't predict that if you don't have
the early indicators but what you can do
you can make the schools safer
cruz says the best way to protect our
kids is to ensure there are armed police
officers
yeah
whoops
he kicked himself out oh there he is
you're welcome back
does that make you just like well here's
the thing that what they want you know
the only option is to sell more guns and
or or wall off the school they were
talking about like you know uh walls and
razor wire and [ __ ] metal detectors
and like why don't you just send your
kids straight to prison
but i mean ted cruz like first of all
what i was trying to play was
uh
yeah but rock who approached abbott and
they all throw him out
i love that guy does he have a chance
yeah yeah he's got a chance he his his
problem is is his whole we're coming for
your guns thing from the democratic
primary which he spoke in absolutes
about just and it's see and it's a clip
that they can use against him in the
same way that like yunkan used um you
know clips of mcauliffe
talking about you know parents don't
have a say in their in their kids
schooling what he meant was you don't
get to interrupt it mid-stream you ha
you're you can go to a uh
one of these you don't get it's not
you don't get to just sporadically pick
what subjects your kid learns in
elementary school it's public school if
you want to do that send them to a
private school um that's that's the
issue so
um i i think he does i think he's going
to end up
you know he's going to have to mitigate
what he's talking about so he can be
more specific so he's not so people
don't think he's rounding up their their
shotguns and their self-defense handguns
and stuff because texas won't just just
won't have that um and and again that's
why you have to be more measured
in your conversation about this because
do you want to get it done or you not
want to get it done do you want to
disqualify yourself right and then and
the argument this goes back to biden and
obama about gay marriage
but um everybody in in obama's camp knew
that at the time
gay marriage was a non-starter it's like
just across the country it was it was
enough to give
um
the you know mccain the edge yeah just
enough right with the evangelical it
would drive out that voter turnout
and it and it would and they were like
oh you can say you're for civil unions
but if you go all the way and say you're
for marriage you're kind of going to
screw us if you're not careful because
and do you want to get it done or do you
want somebody in office who will
guarantee it doesn't happen that's the
mitigatory reality we live in okay
that's just and it's not because the
politicians are lying or have to it's in
some ways to quote brian kinney on queer
as folk it's not a lie if they make you
lie and there's a um you know when he
was talking about people you know being
in the closet versus being out and
there's an element of that with
politicians where it's they're not lying
if we make them live we're all living in
a field of [ __ ] um going don't tell
me the truth i don't want to hear the
truth and they
and you're shocked that the person who
doesn't tell you the whole truth gets
elected it's silly so in the case of
obama he was like i'm for i believe
marriage is between man and one woman i
believe the civil unions should be the
right of everyone and if you want and if
you want to call it a marriage that's a
free speech issue that's where we were
as a country at that time biden comes
out and goes i'm for gay marriage
and he almost screwed the pooch right no
i know
everybody was like shut up
even obama told him to shut up
yeah but that was the thing because
you can't and he was just speaking
honestly
yeah that's the irony
so that's you know
and the same thing kind of applies um to
to this with beto he's not running to be
he's not ready to be governor of vermont
where bernie sanders is an independent
who changed his party affiliation and
his attitude on guns to get elected in
vermont when he was running for mayor
back in the day
he had to change his position on guns to
do it because vermont is a much more gun
positive state
than would than most people assume a
bernie sanders state would be right so
and he's always stayed that way yeah
he'll ask you just a technical question
because i just got a notification from
facebook
you know saying they don't know if it's
on their end but the stream seems to be
going in and out is that do you ever get
that
yeah of course yeah i mean they um
there's all kinds of issues they get
ddos attacks like crazy on facebook
especially right now during the ukraine
war
um like everything's shaky
dedicated yeah dedicated denial of
service so they uh overwhelm them like
they'll have bots sign up you know a
hundred thousand accounts in one second
[ __ ] like that and then they'll then
they'll send a barrage of messages to a
bunch of other stuff that's
this usually kind of thing where you try
to overwhelm the system or they'll try
to they'll intentionally between an hour
of time like upload
you know six hundred thousand hours of
material or attempt to do everyone on
facebook because everyone on facebook is
saying that it's gone
it's just gone i don't think i was
hacked because my passwords are too hard
no no you weren't um you know sometimes
uh on stream yard you can turn off your
you know it'll say what channel you're
streaming to and you turn them off you
might be able to see that i don't know
oh no i have it on facebook i mean i
know so turn it off on facebook and turn
it back on
oh okay that will sometimes do it
because it'll re it'll re-establish the
connection and if the connection was
wonky that's the way i do it sometimes
oh okay let me try that okay yeah
okay yeah okay so i'll so i'll remove it
right
yeah just remove it and then start it
again right away
okay and then start again
sorry distributed denial of service
thank you act
yeah okay i just did that okay we'll see
what happens
it's always good to have a buddy like
cal i'll tell you
so um yeah so again
i put it all on us
sorry i you know i
we have a responsibility anytime you
talk about
the second amendment everybody who's
listening to the sound of my voice
you you have to start using the
well-regulated militia language every
time you mention it
because that's what will drift the
conversation i don't want to get all
frank luntz about this but that's what
will drift the conversation towards like
rational gun control with a lot of the
people who are maybe on the fence
reminding them that the prime
the leading language
of it is
is the the idea that
that a well-regulated militia is
necessary all of that
stuff
yeah just it's just happening yet i'm
sorry i'll just [ __ ] that's okay i
mean no it's i mean it might not be you
so don't worry about it that's the i
don't think it's me because it's because
because you know we're on twitch and
youtube without a problem yep
yep
so
yeah so that's the you know
other than that i have no opinion so has
has beaubert and green and all these
gun-toting loons have they said anything
about
you know about the shooting yet have you
heard because because i hadn't heard
anything
from any of them not elementary school
kids so they suddenly got all quiet if
it's if it's grown people or teenagers
even they're like well you know
citizen is innocent is sin so tough [ __ ]
yeah
it's just it's just you know like
is there anything biden could do is
there any executive order that he can
sign anything no
nothing nothing nope
there's not no the only thing that will
change this aspect is is changes in the
law and we don't have enough dems
selected to do it
jesus it's just
doesn't it doesn't it make you feel so
helpless
no i need you to say that
no
nobody gets to skip history nobody gets
to have a life without horror in it
there's a lot of this stuff going on and
we need to do our best
to to get to write it and the way we do
that
the way we do our best is vote every
time um vote for the democrat period end
of story even if you're holding your
nose i don't give a rat's ass
because ultimately it will the only
thing that's going to put the fear of
god in republicans ultimately is that
they're going to lose even their their
red states after the purple ones go
yeah
yeah medium t is right there's no guns
allowed at the nra convention
all the time well that's what i was
saying like they talk about these
gun-free zones in these gun-free zones
there was an armed guard on that school
grounds and it was a gun-free zone
all the you know all their solutions
worked the problem is it's too [ __ ]
late
that every every solution they have is
an after the fact or a concurrent
solution
when in reality you could have had this
off you headed this off at the pass
yeah
uh herschel walker claims he graduated
in the top 1 of his university of
georgia class
he never graduated
how does this guy have a chance hal
[Laughter]
no warnock's gonna kick his ass he's
very popular he's very competent the
that you know the the mega crowd is
gonna rally behind herschel walker he'll
get more votes than he should
but he's not gonna win
what is
your
um prediction when it comes since you
are never wrong
what's your prediction with donald trump
is he gonna run no
and is it because he has a health issue
uh uh i don't i don't i mean i know he's
full of [ __ ] if that's what you're
talking about um like that would be
that's unhealthy i'm just he's so full
of [ __ ] it's like they sold his [ __ ]
[ __ ]
um
um
no he's not gonna run he's not gonna run
because he hates it beyond it you know
it this is all a scam understand that
all of this was a scam he didn't want to
win in the first [ __ ] place he was
miserable the whole time he was there
and do you think for a [ __ ] second
that anything would change if he was
president again you think if you have
less scrutiny around him are you out of
your [ __ ] mind
like he would he won't even release his
taxes from the four years between when
he was out of office and when he would
back be back in office it's not going to
happen
and and quite frankly there are a lot of
republicans he's already on a hard fade
i mean he's he's like i i 100 and lost
six or whatever yeah the six ones were
purdue
you know like they're huge and the ma
and the ones he's one are like these
state reps that are the only ones
getting money from the party so of
course they're gonna [ __ ] win
like he's and he's doing this he's doing
the same mistake that sometimes like um
like hyper progressive dems do with this
idea of turning blues blue areas bluer
he's turning red areas redder
you know um and so what you know what i
mean like mtg
more than likely there's going to be a
republican in that seat even without her
right
is she worse yes
it doesn't [ __ ] matter she's got the
same number of votes in the house
it's a bunch of fart air she never
produces any bills she's not on any
committees because she's because of her
jan 6 [ __ ] so ultimately she's less
damaging to our democracy than a
functioning republican in that seat
yeah
if you think of it this way and this is
where i'm trying to convince people
about the whole like mansion cinema [ __ ]
and not to worry about it
mansion and cinema are in seats that
would otherwise be occupied by a
republican many times they have and the
democrat you're going to get in that
seat is not going to be anything like
sanders aoc or even a biden democrat
sorry that's how it works um the
but
they are more effective for us
than a baseline republican and a maggot
in that seat
would be even you know would basically
even it out that's why the republicans
have to run somebody relatively sensible
even against mansion because of that
balancing act and he's making a good
show of it it's going to be really hard
to kind of purge him eventually by from
republican standards because they're
going to have to run somebody that's
more like kasich to even get anywhere
[ __ ] near him to get him elect you
know get them elected and they can't run
any of those people because of trump
they're screwing their own system it's
hilarious
but uh
did you see that um i guess
ivanka has to testify along with jared
to the
uh like in new york
yeah
because they're [ __ ] criminals
i'm fine with that so as so as martha
salinas asks you and you are the
resident genius how
sparks is trump going in prison
um
no
he he's gonna get fined like crazy he'll
have a trial if he ever gets to the
point where they're going to put him in
jail for a period of time
then he'll get really sick
and he'll demand that he you know he
he'll go to the hospital and he'll
remain in the hospital for six months
you know on on [ __ ] life support
with uh basically coming and going from
the icu the way
jeffrey epstein came and went from the
local jail in lauderdale or wherever the
[ __ ] that was
but um no i don't see him going to jail
for this stuff i see a lot of fines in
his future and the dissolution of the
trump organization which is a bigger
nightmare for them and that's why by the
way he's running off of the save america
pack like a tick
and he can't live without it if he runs
he can't have that money
yeah and his campaign money has to be
spent on very specific things and he is
paying his bills his debts
his interest on his loans and principal
with save america pac money mm-hmm
yeah he's gonna he's declaring
this man
he'll declare bankruptcy in the next you
know two years
i mean he was if if he hadn't won the
presidency his properties would already
be in probate yeah
yeah i mean if you think
look how many failed businesses that guy
has and i found it amazing people call
him a successful businessman oh it's
ridiculous
when he a lot of people know this but
when he wrote art of the deal he it was
the same year he lost more money in new
york real estate than any human being in
history
and then he and then his like second
book or whatever he wrote through a
ghost writer that was the year that was
in 91 92 or whatever that was the same
year he had to borrow 56 million dollars
from his brother and sister's trust fund
money just to keep the lights on at
trump organization running money cash in
hand because he couldn't get
a loan to roll through what what they
were bullshitting everyone was a
downturn what ultimately
kept the company afloat
was money coming in on property already
owned that his father had set up and
established and turning the company into
a branding exercise and even that
started to fade over time because he
couldn't build anything new had to wait
for somebody else to build and and try
to make a deal to slap his name on it
and and and that money was going away
and then all of a sudden they couldn't
get [ __ ] and then magically deutsche
bank russia money comes out of nowhere
as these [ __ ] start to like you know
he's been talking about this and he's an
easily manipulated [ __ ]
so maybe we he's maybe he's our spoiler
even if he doesn't win
he's a chaos agent so we'll just start
funneling money his direction keep him
afloat mark burnett famously goes over
to do the show with about vladimir putin
comes back with the idea to do a show
about donald trump
you know has half the secures half the
funding so he can own half the show
that wasn't his own [ __ ] money where
did it come from
he's the one hiding the the n-word tapes
and all that [ __ ] i mean it's sketchy as
[ __ ] but again
um
there is no way this works out for trump
i got news for you
like
misery horror crap
[ __ ] like it's just like life down a
sewer
that's and and there was even an article
today i want to say on like
um might have been daily beasts so
they're like mega without trump there's
all these articles that are starting to
show up
um called you know mega without trump
and it's and they're not and they're not
kidding they're not these aren't
spoilers these aren't they're not
[ __ ] around they mean it
thanks agent for the two but i guess
something's wrong with facebook today
yeah
i can't worry about it anymore just come
and watch on youtube yeah um
you have to go right like
so who are you headed to
um i've got uh family stuff this
afternoon so all right
and then i've got another interview to
do and then i've got my show and yeah so
it's a lot well listen i love when
you're on it go so quickly i know
but i love your intelligence it's always
fun to hear from you is there anything
that you'd like to plug
yeah i'll be on a four o'clock today
infotainmentwars.com uh we're at 35 000
subscribers very excited we're on that
bullet train to a hundred thousand by
god it'll happen i'm trusting that it
will happen we're growing you know it's
every next big 5 000 leap seems to come
quicker and that's a good sign um and
and even still because my chat room is
full of genuine people instead of bots
and and you know even when the trolls
show up they they they get broomed
pretty quickly um by people just because
they don't they have no impact um so
anyways uh and then ad house sparks on
instagram and twitter people can follow
me there and my favorite one
flank
fwanq dot com flank that'll take you
thanks
um no that's why i'm all the ocean
oh so that's also pronounced danish
oh yeah
she just got out of the hospital so i
thought
yeah
well i'm glad you got out that's
wonderful bless you and i i wish you
good health and and happy days um so
um i will yeah we will be dealing with
some of this stuff uh later on or
whatever but i will be mainly just uh
spiking the ball on these fear farmers
that are trying to sell everybody on the
end of the world so um take care of
yourself take care of somebody else i
gotta run i love you pal yeah thanks for
having me okay all right bye bye
everybody at the great house sparks and
i'm gonna bring tony michaels in
who is uh another great guest to the
show tony let me just i gotta just do a
little ad go ahead go ahead
are you a betting man
no
really no no couldn't get me to bed on
[ __ ] i i make i didn't work hard for my
money huh not even the cardinals no no
no i did i did make a bet yesterday my
bet yesterday was that beto o'rourke
does not tan his ball sack i i will bet
on that
what
i i bet that bet o'rourke does not tan
his ballsack he's too
you've seen yesterday when he went after
greg abbott i think he's got a big set
of balls and he's manly and he doesn't
need to tan his ballsack like tucker
carlson that's all i'm saying
well look uh our partners at
fedonline.ag continue to be to be the
number one source for all your betting
needs and sports info find all of the
latest odds news and sports developments
including this year's basketball
playoffs major league baseball scores
fights and even next season's nfl
futures
uh
uh but online.ag is a continued source
for all your sports wagering needs
including live betting and of course
your favorite vegas casino and poker
games it's really easy to get started so
head to the website today or use your
mobile device to sign up today and use
our our promo code clns50.clns50
to receive your 50 welcome bonus on your
first deposit bet online.ag where the
game starts and i do bet and i do use
bet online.ag so i'm not only uh
the uh deliver of their message i'm also
a fan uh benny loco i have to give
andrea the wrench uh on next podcast i
forgot to do it today and andrea sorry
you can't watch on facebook but you sure
can get on youtube right now i'm having
a facebook issue today tony tony i got
to tell you something i've got a lot of
issues about facebook but you know that
that probably they're here they're in
there
what do you got john
i did a show yesterday you know it's you
know it was for a friend of mine
and yet you know the questioning was all
about what the trolls are saying and all
and kevin
and kevin and kevin yeah are
kevin what do i podcast i can't be in
the game i kept using your line and
kevin what
from why do i podcast
i just love that line though
yeah that's from beer in a balcony
they're really they're really uh mad
that uh apparently i don't know i
haven't seen the clips yet apparently
they haven't ripped it out of your uh
you're behind your paywall so that they
oh yeah how did you find out that they
were mad
someone tweeted that [ __ ] at me i know i
don't know i don't know they they tweet
it they tweet they tweet [ __ ] at me all
the time they're like you know tony
michaels is on like breaking news tony
michaels is on stuttering john's podcast
and i'm like yeah breaking [ __ ] news
like what are you talking about like
[Laughter]
as if you're trying to hide it or
something like it's some kind of [ __ ]
speaker
you know this [ __ ] is on [ __ ] youtube
and sometimes on facebook depending on
the day but it's on youtube and twitch
and i mean it's not a [ __ ] secret
when people are on your show like you're
tweeting it out i don't understand
i know it's just it's just
i found it hysterical that you were able
to like just call this [ __ ] out for all
that he is and you know like just i mean
just
my favorite line that you said tony and
i i was thinking about it uh today was
just when you said
i don't know why he wants to take you
down if he does he'll have no show yeah
well he won't have any content i don't
know if anyone's you know paid attention
to these [ __ ] idiots probably not but
um if you haven't paid attention to him
like his entire youtube channel like the
entire thing
is just john like it's just john i know
and i don't understand like like i like
to come on here and goof at you like i i
goof on you you don't understand why
they have to create a whole youtube
channel take your content and then goof
on you like there's some kind of tough
guy or something i know i don't
understand that
i don't understand no i i'm glad that
you called the you know but you know
yeah sure but he's just uh you know like
but
the point i was trying to make is this
is the person who interviewed me was
asking me all these things about
about the trolls and there are 2 000 of
them john that are on
this hate site on reddit and they're all
and i'm like
i go you know let me ask you a question
okay let's say there's 2 000.
that is like .00009
of the people who know me
as being an entertaining guy on two of
the most successful
tv and radio shows in history
they don't [ __ ] go on there they
don't know a thing about what these
losers are talking about and nor do they
care right well that's what i'm saying
so like when they when they tweet [ __ ]
at me right like about about you being
on your show or something
no one sees it like
sometimes i feel like i should give them
a like because i feel sorry for them
like a petty like like oh they got two
likes i might give them another one oh
man
they're so path it's so [ __ ] pathetic
and and the other thing too is like
they're always they're always posting
[ __ ]
about
you that you can find anywhere else like
it's not like you can't find this [ __ ]
oh here's the best tony so
i mean this is the best so you know so
kevin from what is it again uh why why
do i podcast well i don't believe that's
what his show is yeah why why do i
bought gas yeah i mean
right so he does a whole show in
nashville i think you told me this yeah
yeah so he he he did a he had a venue
and they did a live show and me and you
were of course it was you that were the
headliner of course but you know i i'm
i'm the second fiddle and gabe you know
they make fun of him as he's like the
third fiddle or something i'm like you
[ __ ] rented a stage
to goof on us
like you rented a [ __ ] stage
was there an ass
well i mean there was tens of people
probably but you know
but here's my favorite thing tony that
and
is he started calling me delusional
because i said i beat shaq in basketball
now he does a whole show with the title
star wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
he's he says you said that that you were
going to beat shaq and basketball i
don't know i don't know this i think
someone's tweeted this [ __ ] at me before
but yeah
i'm telling you the story he is claiming
that i'm delusional for making the claim
that i'd beat shaq in basketball okay
sounds like you did or you can
i i did okay okay okay okay so of course
he's saying i'm delusional it must not
be true
what do i do he doesn't realize that
dumb [ __ ] is that it's
it was it was on the tonight show it was
the whole corresponding speech where i
would challenge shaq
to a game
it was not scripted it was it was it was
a reality thing and shaq was so cocky
that i took the ball like he had the
ball he comes out i'm so short he's so
tall you just like ran underneath his
legs or some [ __ ] right yeah i ran
around and stole the ball
and i suck at basketball i take
a shot from way beyond the three-point
line
and switch it
so you got [ __ ] lucky this isn't like
chattering john is a great basketball
player yes and he whipped the [ __ ] out
of shaq i got lucky but he's not getting
lucky but it's it's true and you see
shaq's reaction he's so pissed off
but the great thing tony is that this
idiot kevin from why do i podcast yeah
he's trying like
he does a whole show calling me
delusional where the dumb [ __ ] doesn't
even know i have it all on tape
well you know the tonight show was on
tape a lot i mean
he did have a lot of tape of that so he
did so he
like
it's like
they conjure up these lies
and they sell these lies
and then
then when i show them the video i have
one guy on patreon oh that must have
been scripted oh yeah well but but
here's the thing here's the thing stop
acting and [ __ ] really you think he
could act right check check shaq is as
bad at acting as you are at basketball
probably
listen
here's the thing is that they don't have
they don't really they don't have to
show evidence like if even if you show
it they don't have to clip out that part
of your show because they only clip out
the parts that they want right like yes
like they're only clipping out the parts
that they want right and and it just and
they're gonna clip this this part too
the [ __ ] that they want they'll probably
clip the [ __ ] out where you know they
really don't like what i'm saying
because it is tough to you know when you
when you actually rent a [ __ ] stage
in nashville to goof on john
and goof on me and gabe goofing on john
you know it it really is kind of [ __ ]
pathetic
that's your only stick like you can't
create content other than that like
that's the only way that you can create
content it really is i mean pathetic but
amusing it's hilarious it's hilarious
because here's the other thing it's
hilarious for the wrong reasons well
right right but but here's the thing is
that these people tweeted me and tweeted
me and um last i bear on the balcony for
anyone who doesn't know i i said on the
show that's uh what's his name that the
guy
that um you interviewed uh no no no no
that's it shulie um i i looked this guy
up because he kept retweeting [ __ ] and
kept liking stuff and i looked the guy
up because i didn't know who the [ __ ] he
was what he does right and i looked i
looked him up and half his [ __ ]
twitter following is fake they're all
fake accounts and i said that on the
show and almost immediately they were
tweeting tony michaels claims that
julie's half his twitter followers are
fake and i'm like they are you go
[ __ ] just look at the evidence i
don't know what to tell you i didn't
make this [ __ ] up i don't like this [ __ ]
up i don't know who shuli is i don't
give a [ __ ] who julius it's just he's
always in my [ __ ] mentions like
always like here's a guy here's a guy
who claims that he's you know the [ __ ]
or whatever he's part of stern show
history right whatever any and he's on
he's on kevin's why do i podcast show
every once in a while you know they they
[ __ ] around together they goof they goof
on you because they wouldn't have any
content otherwise but here's the thing
is that half his followers are fake
right yeah and they're like oh they're
not fake you don't have no proof and
then i sent the proof i think gabe
posted i think you post because i don't
really engage with these [ __ ] idiots
on twitter but um gabe was really
goofing on him with gifts it was
hilarious the other day he was really
goofing on well you showed me the actual
documentation yeah yeah
right and he's [ __ ] that he bought
right half his followers it's like
almost 49 so half his followers are fake
they're not real accounts which which in
in reality most most people who have a
twitter account a lot of them are fake
right so like um
like i i think i think i wouldn't even
know how to buy twitter followers right
well i i mean most people like like your
account my account most people's account
on twitter you know you're gonna have
anywhere between like four and seven
maybe eight percent that's fake right
but you can't help it because they're
following you right the bots are
following you so there's nothing you can
really do about it but when you get over
that 10 15 percent mark there's
something fishy it sucks right it's
really [ __ ] sucks the other the other
uh the other great um
great lie they tell is you had eric
swalwell on your show i think i
retweeted i retweeted the clip that you
played yeah
you claimed on the beer on the balcony i
think that's where it was you claimed on
the beer in the balcony when we were
talking that you had over 10 000 views
on that video and they kept posting
screenshots with me tagged on it i'm
like what stop [ __ ] posting
screenshots of john's youtube i know
where it's at i know where his [ __ ]
youtube is at you do not have to show it
to me but these dumb [ __ ] would
post a a screenshot and it'd be like oh
it's got it's got 3 200 views or
something like that or i don't know like
oh not even anywhere close to 10 000.
what they don't know is if you go to
twitter you dumb [ __ ] and look
at the clip that john posted it's got
over 20 000 views i
they really try to find the [ __ ] that
like
and there's plenty of stuff that's true
about john that you can goof on there's
plenty guys there's plenty of stuff and
i'm here to tell you that i love coming
on the show and goofing on john and me
and john goof even off the show
i don't understand why they have to make
[ __ ] up to goof you and i think it's
because it's their ego and and they you
know they're they're these [ __ ] macho
machismo these he's probably trumped up
[ __ ] you know they're always
retweeting elon and all this [ __ ] these
[ __ ] you know they think he's some kind
of big badass which he's not he you know
but here's the thing
is that guys
kevin shuley all you people out there
that are goofing on john you don't have
to make the [ __ ] up to goof on john you
don't have to
he's he's plenty i mean the guy the guy
is not good at basketball even though he
got lucky and made a shot with shaq you
can take that video and you can go i'm
not going to golf but i beat tom giosano
what do you want now now you're really
going to cause the controversy now
you're going to really know that's on
video too no no you're going to cause it
they're going to say you're lying
and he's practically semi-pro yeah well
you know yeah look
here look i'm gonna share this with
everybody just so you can see and i and
i appreciate i know we got off the
politics but you know what
you know it doesn't bother me i talk you
know
you know like like i need to have this
laugh yeah yeah there there's the uh
there's the screenshot and i think
look
48.9
fake followers
should we bring gabe on the show
because he's the one that looked this up
let me let me text him yeah i mean
dare i mean how pathetic are you
that you have to buy followers
and now here check this out dude do you
see that one yeah what's that what's the
video account on that one okay 19 000.
19.9 000. we've got almost 20 000. yeah
you claimed you claimed 10 i think is
when yes i did but it's gone up since
then
so
here's the thing i don't lie tony
you know i mean it's like
like
how could you lie about something
that could easily be looked up you know
what i mean
well i mean they probably don't know it
can be looked up right like i mean i
mean
seems like i mean if you're if you're
probably you know naive enough to think
that you can buy you know
60 70 000 followers and think that no
one can find out how that you bought
sixty or seventy thousand followers he's
probably that naive i mean he's probably
not he's not cost did you ask come on
cause i'm sure he knows yeah i i don't
know if he's busy or not i i text him
early and told him why he's coming on
and he gave me a thumbs up but he didn't
say hey i i'd like so i don't know so i
just text him we'll see if he uh yeah i
joined
because i only have um
uh
i have to go at uh you know at 4 30
today because oh dear what what the hell
you got going on
i'm doing this podcast he says he's he
says he's coming right on so he'll be
here in a minute we can ask him about
the uh the data on shulie
but it's just it's just so sad and
pathetic you know oh here's gabe
hey gabe hey what's going on i'm just
talking about your brilliant uh twitter
research to find out oh yeah
that shirley bought half his fault
how uh
how how does that how does one do that
and how much does that cost
john wants to up his following
yeah yeah
i would never do that yeah i'd
considered us buying a million dollars
if i could afford it why not elon musk
has 13 million i mean you can you can
easily track this kind of stuff but i
mean like on average you could probably
buy twitter followers because they do
them in buckets
so you could do
uh let's say that you wanted to buy
how many like 25 000 yeah
yeah it would cost you the auction in a
month
659.70
for 25 000 how many fake followers does
he have let's see how much it would cost
so probably a thousand bucks
no what's the how many fake followers do
they have um well it's like a hundred
and probably 180 i think it's only 100
that's how many followers he had i think
yeah i think he has like 80 000. yeah so
80 or 90 fake yeah
all right 80 000
uh it would cost you about two grand
2100 yeah well you know and you could
you could find you can find probably
cheaper and more expensive it depends on
like the quality of the bots that you're
buying but for the most part you know
probably 2k you probably said hey hey do
you have good bots or bad bots we want
to know
the only way hey john the only way to
stop a bad bot is a good bot that's yeah
you know what tony and gabe
you know i'm glad you guys are here
because you give me prime for the next
i'm gonna do where i'm really gonna tear
into truly but
i will say this even though he's a
nobody and i don't usually punch down
but i'm enjoying it too much but you all
three of us did
my show
after i went to dc yeah yeah yeah and we
all goofed on it we all goofed on me and
we goofed on the camera crew you know
we all did our own trolling of ours at
least every like including myself we all
trolled me on that one
i mean we just goofed on the whole
[ __ ] you know
john
john you hired a craigslist porno so
yeah of course we moved on you so the
whole thing we made it
we made it funny right and then carl
does this i mean kevin i'm sorry he does
a show
to say that um
my dc trip was a big failure yeah
we already said that dummy
at least come up with your own angle you
prick
that's the thing i think that's the
funniest part is like and tony said it
on the on the the weekend show which was
how much they rely on your content if
you don't produce content they have
nothing to talk about because i have not
seen anything where they're like hey
this is so we're gonna make original
content it's them just
trying to rag on you right it's mostly
every once in a while they do one on
them
ah what's this what's this guy's name
opie yeah yeah
they do one on over every once in a
while but the other so the other thing
too is so i just took a look at shulie's
uh account at his analytics yeah and in
let's see i can tell you where there
where twitter goes through and it
basically
it comes through and it cleans house on
what it knows bots are so like
in
2018 he lost about 1800 followers
had some dips here and there how do you
lose followers
because twitter goes through when
they're like all right these are these
are fake accounts
and they dump them uh in february of
2021 he lost almost a thousand followers
which also syncs up with a bunch of
tweets he was doing but yeah i mean you
can look through and you can find where
the where where twitter basically says
all right i'm dropping you a few hundred
i'm dropping you this and they're all
happening on
uh single days
which means that
you're not getting 300 400 500 people
that are just like oh you know what i'm
going to unfollow yeah you never know
you never never yeah yeah well i don't
know maybe he said something stand up
you're probably dropping that quickly
right but twitter's going through and
like these are fake accounts we got to
kill them and then they go off and then
you lose followers and that's how it
works
so i've had comedy club owners go to me
i booked surely i would never book that
guy again he doesn't have a joke he goes
johnny he doesn't have a joke and these
i mean you might say that julie is there
i said you might say that shulie is the
joke so he shows up that it's a one bit
it's like boom done and he's like well
that's my time folks gotta go
we're sure you guys picking on julie you
know you know john wait tony before you
go to i don't
he started it with me not not the other
way around oh i'll goof on julie i don't
give a [ __ ] i goof on gabe every day i
don't give a [ __ ] it doesn't matter to
me
each other
i mean i i would i would go
i would go on kevin's show and goof him
goofing you like you take the trifecta
here we do your show right and then he
he steals the [ __ ] footage right and
then he cuts it down and then i go on
his show and he's goofing on you and
goofing on me uh he's goofing on me
goofing on you and then i goof on him
goofing on me gooping on you think about
this think about the dichotomy think
about the deep levels here
of of why do i podcast and kevin of how
deep this could actually go this is one
thing i do want to point out
i
sincerely before this whole thing
happened i did not know who shuli was
now you could also say i didn't know who
you are gabe and i could be like yeah i
don't know who i am either right and
that's the joke i'm able to make fun of
myself but julie and probably others
like who do that podcast are like
i take it so seriously and i think it's
a bud hurt and then it's like
you know what i'm sure i'm sure i
guarantee they're gonna clip out that
one thing right there and make fun of me
and i don't really care yeah [ __ ] them
here's the thing here's the thing gabe
the best part is they're so famous
they're so famous the these why do i
podcast guys that they rented a stage in
nashville to talk about us that's how
[ __ ] that's how famous they are
that's how [ __ ] famous they are
they're goofing they're goofing on
nobodies like tony michaels and gabe
sanchez
that that went on that went on
stuttering john who no one likes
apparently and they read it a whole
[ __ ] state they're so famous enough
about my family
oh my god he's [ __ ] guys but that's
the thing gabe like the whole thing
nobody knows who kevin is nobody knows
who julia's and they can't stand that a
lot of people know who i am and that's
what and they're they're in lies the
basis of everything yeah they hate
even though i got lucky tony playing
shaq i beat him fair and square you get
lucky every goddamn day john yeah every
day not just with shag i've lived in
charm life last night guys
just i dated a girl who happens to work
at the hard rock can you say this on
youtube i just want to make sure first
before yeah in florida
it just so turns out the dude i'm
staying with
is going to see paul mccartney at the
hard rock
so i you know so i go on a date with the
girl i go hey if you want she goes if
you want you can come see paul mccartney
this is how charmed i got to tell you
this because this is how charmed that my
life is
so she gets me tickets in the 200s
what's a good seeds
as i walk in the security i go
john
i go yeah he goes stuttering john
i go yeah he goes grab a picture and i
go yeah and he goes
let me take a picture of your ticket i'm
getting your wristband and you're going
to be right on the floor
and then within another minute another
security guy comes up stuttering john
can i have a picture here's your here's
your wristband
now
is that ever going to happen to kevin is
that ever going to happen to julie no
no no
no well here's what i'll tell you here's
the day right now they're tweeting on
twitter breaking news
john
stuttering john melendez and tony
michael's claims they were at the hard
rock [ __ ] paul mccartney in the ass i
mean
they're literally going to say some
crazy ass [ __ ] they're probably tweeting
it right now let me go check my mentions
oh there he goes
boom there it is that's it that's
these these guys these guys really do
need to get it's hard it's i will say
that like when you when you try to clown
on someone who's already clowning on
themselves yeah right like
that's the the humor of of
of self-deprecation
is great you know but when somebody
tries to then [ __ ] on you for what you
made fun of yourself for
that's it kind of like loses what's so
funny
is that we all
all three of us dissected that dc trip
and did two hours
goofing on it yeah not one of us said it
was great because it wasn't
yeah we all goofed on it so
you know then like
it's like okay we already did that bit
right you know come up with something
new
they're like we're going to talk about
the lighting but they already mentioned
the lighting
we're going to talk about the question
we already talked about the question
we're going to talk about how bad i look
in a suit we already talked about that
too
you know i look horrible in suits that's
why i don't wear it just the suit just
to suit john really
dude i think i look pretty handsome now
you fat
do you
do you do you get your suits off
craigslist too i mean you get your porno
what happened was this was the big and i
did an interview yesterday but why would
you
not why did you borrow your brother's
suit i go because he lives in new york
we're the same size why should i carry a
[ __ ] suit across the country when i
don't have to
first to florida then to new york then
to dc then back to [ __ ] new york and
then back to california when i don't
have to
and my suit i look no better in
right
but also if they're like oh you got to
buy a new suit for that it's like do i
if i'm doing something for a day two
days max where i have to have it on in
front of a camera
it's like
what is the roi there i'm not really
making any money on buying a suit and
doing the video might as well just
borrow the suit and do the video right i
mean definitely go on craigslist and
find one here's what i'll tell you yeah
about clothes and podcasting
listen kevin if you want to do take a
clip here's where you start the clip put
your mark here for your editing
i rarely even wear pants when i'm
podcasting yeah i rarely even wear pants
breaking news breaking news on
stuttering john's podcast tony michaels
now i wear shorts but i very rarely wear
pants and i don't even hardly wear shoes
even i just i just don't why would i you
don't see anything every morning tony
sends me a pic he goes pants check and
then
it's not the most obviously
good thing to do in the morning when i
wake up i'm like whoa i'm up let's go
john
um
i don't know
why
these guys have gotten so obsessed with
you i'm not exactly sure and i think a
little bit like you said is jealousy but
i gotta
isn't well but here's what i think it
actually is
is that you wouldn't invite them because
you have no [ __ ] clue who they are on
your show to goof on you
so the best option for them to create
content
is to take your show and to goof on you
because for for whatever reason so
um but i'm a d-list
a celebrity at best you know i don't
even know we're gonna try and use that
against you now you said it yeah
you know i've had my time in the sun i'm
fine with being where i am now well but
but that that's what i'm saying though
is what i what i'm suggesting here is
what you should do
is um you should tell kevin from why do
i podcast if he wants to goof on you so
much
and and maybe you're against this but
i i would go on kevin's stupid ass show
and again goof on you
while i goof on me goofing on you
goofing on his shin i don't know it's
very confusing how he does it but maybe
maybe you should tell kevin that if he
really wants to goof on you that bad
because i know he would say no hell no i
there's no way i would do that because
he wouldn't appear on this show no
[ __ ] way would he have the guts to
appear on this show no [ __ ] way would
he appear i would come on his show hell
i come on your show for crying out loud
why i have no idea but you're like hey
were you coming to show i'm like yeah
sure but fine we'll goof on you or we'll
goof on your dc footage or we'll we'll
talk about politics which we didn't talk
about politics today which i'm kind of
excited because um there's so much going
on in the world i know um and i've been
yelling and screaming for like two hours
the last couple days literally yelling
and screaming yeah if anyone's out there
watching i don't know i just did a whole
hour without
yeah i've seen i've seen a lot of your
uh your part with alan so i appreciate
the uh break from the monotony of um
yeah i've happened to be pissed but i
want everyone out there to know that you
should stay pissed you should be pissed
about what's going on in the world um
take take your breaks because um
you're gonna need them because they're
not gonna stop these fascists are not
gonna stop um and you should take a few
breaks now and then to laugh and you
know goof on john goof on kevin thanks
kevin for letting us and julie too
thanks for letting us goof on this thing
i don't even know who this is it kevin
is it carl is it clan
i called him kevin
[ __ ] yeah okay got it
like i said i don't even know you know
like me all before this happened i don't
even know who truly is i'm not even sure
still who he is i don't know i know i i
don't know i asked this girl who's a big
stern fan who was interviewing me i said
has truly done anything of any note on
the stern show and she's like no who's
this not this girl that interviewed you
this this girl uh monique she's from uh
it's called uh ah radio gunk
but oh okay yeah yeah yeah yeah but
because i don't know i go has he has he
done anything on the show of any comedic
note and she goes no
no i mean not one
you know
he claims to be a stand-up right and
then i mean
but you know yeah he's a real
[Laughter]
here's the thing only half of his
followers even know who he is because he
bought the other half yeah
that's probably not i don't know
but listen
it's almost as bad as it is
tony gabe i love you guys please plug
anything that you want gabe tell them
tell them where we're at
every day monday through friday you can
find us two hours from 12 to 2 p.m
eastern on the tony michaels podcast you
can find us on youtube uh we have shows
on saturday and sunday where we rehash
kind of the best moments of the week and
you can also catch us we're going to be
doing the live streaming of the january
6th
uh hearings starting june 9th
yeah i mean i had the minus touch
brothers on here first
like the i was the first show they ever
did and now they're [ __ ] used so i
hope the same thing happens to you guys
yeah we appreciate it we appreciate it
john and mike tony thank you so much
for you know always always you know you
know always coming on
at the last minute i appreciate yeah no
problem no problem i i was i was unsure
today but uh i made it so that's that's
the important part so thanks all right
guys appreciate it we'll see you guys if
i'm ever in
you're in missouri right
yeah you're i'm not you're not visiting
when i'm when you're in missouri you're
not
no no i mean i mean
don't don't call me you're not looking
at me do not call me i'm in montana i'm
in montana
i'm in my or mississippi maybe
all right
we'll see all right i'll see you man
have a good one see you all right all
right the great gabe sanchez and tony
michaels always makes me laugh and let
me thank house sparks as well uh
you know how tony and gabe and this was
a lot of fun
after a lot of sorrow and uh so
it was nice to just take a break from
the sadness that we all are feeling at
the these innocent children
you know i mean it got killed and i'm
like i tweeted out how many more
how many more ted cruz how many more
kevin mccarthy how many more
mitch mcconnell
how many more
jim jordan before you do something
how many more children have to die
innocent kids how many [ __ ] more
do you have a heart
do you care
enough is enough
because it gets me [ __ ] pissed off
every single time i think about it sorry
for the language mom
but it really [ __ ] pisses me off
and it makes me sad for those parents
and for those poor kids
who were just going
their school years about to end they're
going to have a summer break
pending and the republican party will do
[ __ ] absolutely nothing
just remember that
turn the midterms vote blue like your
life depends on it because it does
and if not yours it could be your kid's
life it could be your friend's life it
could be your family members
because what's going on is a is a
pandemic of gun violence
everywhere
every [ __ ] city
and i'm [ __ ] sick of it
do something
all right guys thanks for coming i'll be
back on saturday sorry i had a shortened
show i got to take a 90 minute ride to
uh
with the west palm
beach so uh i'll i'll be back here on on
saturday at noon pst
uh let me thank my moderators nikki b
and benny loco and soon to be andrea
brower let me also thank my um
paypal donators in any of the super
chats that came in and also i'll thank
my sponsor but online.ag
and we have a brand new show on saturday
um
and uh
god bless you all